[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen
dies wäre es heute geht ein richtig
leckeres rezept und war aus meinem
vorratsschrank weniger vollmann den
kühlschrank geschaut ich hab auch noch
ganz viel paprika übrig und habe mir
gedacht daraus machen wir heute ein
rezept wir machen heute eine pasta
carbonara also mit einer richtig
leckeren paprika soße hier seht ihr wie
ihr braucht wirklich nur ganz wenige
zutaten können im prinzip reinschmeißen
was ihr kater hat und ich zweimal
geführt haben und so schafft speiseplan
hipster nach was man noch und schreit er
übrig war
ich habe mir ja könnt auch eine neue
serie werden was ist installiert
kühlschrank und dann mache ich auf und
gucken wir noch und büros kann sich die
ganze stadt verbringt er bisher daraus
ja meistens weil ich ein großen fach
habe immer noch wird aber naja was soll
ich zeige euch jetzt informant geführt
hatten
für das rezept braucht ihr fünf
paprikaschoten da können wir wirklich
ganz verschiedene nehmen eine rote
zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe 2 chilischoten
zwei esslöffel balsamico habe ich jetzt
im dunklen 70 milliliter olivenöl etwas
salz und pfeffer 100 gramm pasta vorne
von bertram parmesan ich habe ich vier
bis fünf petersilien stelle eine hand
voll basilikumblätter und ich noch
nudeln und war von bis 500 gramm speed
reading aber ihr könnt auch nudeln eurer
wahrnehmen wie zum beispiel falle also
der schmetterlinge oder zum beispiel
auch panel oder wasser zuerst einmal
besser die paprika war nämlich jetzt den
strom genannten weg und das kerngehäuse
geht am besten wenn er die obere einem
daumen drückt und dann kann man hier
unten
denkt mal nach oder dem boden
abschneiden ganze hier sitzen locker
komplett aufdrücken
die paprika die wird dann in streifen
geschnitten
[Musik]
als nächstes durch klebe dran
die halbierten schneider den haag
bringen
und die café wird auch fein geschnitten
und natürlich auch sie zusätzlich
schütten und falls jetzt nicht gerne
sofort willst dann lass dir sie weg und
nicht nur eine
do
frei geschnitten jetzt gibt es das
olivenöl in einem großen topf und den
erhebt es jetzt auch mittel hoher hitze
und hier kommen jetzt die paprika stücke
mit ryan und werden dann bei mittlerer
stufe vi ausgedünnt wird gibt es auch
gleich den deckel mit drauf und das
ganze dauert und so etwa 15 minuten zu
können sie wirklich das volle aroma
entfalten und später kommen sein erstes
unbeständigen und die knoblauchzehe dazu
[Musik]
und es riecht lecker in pakistan
jetzt fühlt sich das fibl unsere
knobloch will und was ich auch dass
viele sind so wie kommen jetzt zu sein
und das ganze darf noch mal etwa 80
minuten schmoren und jetzt hier schon
mal nudeln unserer offenen und auch zwei
esslöffel salz mit rein gegeben und die
betätigung rhein und die müsst ihr
einfach nach packungsanleitung kochen
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich noch
die kräuter fein hacken und den parmesan
reiben und dann muss ich nur noch alles
zusammenfügen
[Musik]
doch zum gemüse gebe ich jetzt in
balsamico essig dass er verfolgt jetzt
ein bisschen dann kurz durch für jetzt
kommen meisterkrone und parmesan mit
rein und die machen das ganz schön
kriegen was du wieder aufgekocht und
gerne auch mit salz und pfeffer würzen
beim schalten sie den ausfall bringen in
termes haben willst du einfach gut
abschmecken und ein bisschen mehr was
aber mehr sagt nicht mehr sein
und ich habe es gleich noch die nudeln
abschnitten und dann kommt die kräuter
noch zuschlug mit rein
die nudeln käse fangen jetzt noch ein
bisschen von dem ab was von dem
kochwasser absolute waffe kommt nämlich
hier gleich mal ein zwei schubkarren
dazu geben jetzt einfach ein bisschen
musiker jetzt sieben minuten ab und dann
geht weiter
[Musik]
da wird meist aber von einem bestellt
mit einer gabel mit einem lachen aber
nicht so wie das ist jetzt seine beste
szene
ich finde ich ziemlich sprachbegabten
das schuljahr französisch englisch
deutsch türkisch hallo hab gewähren
erklärt
und gleich am ende ja mal wieder sagen
minute selbst gemacht was ich muss
ehrlich sagen ehrlich sagen also das
erkennt man nicht aus der al dente sind
wir hoch geschmissen und die sind da
nicht hängen geblieben aber sie waren
schon alle und ehrlich sagen kann
schlecht zurecht ist von den
marktprognosen feuer
nein es ist keine produktion es ist
wirklich lecker ich weiß nicht
vielleicht auch anders zuvor
jedenfalls ist es wirklich ein super
einfach selbst und gerade wenn man mal
viel paprika gekauft hat und vielleicht
schon so ein bisschen weich und dann
will man sich nach essen und dann
aber schlag auf den punkt
auch alle hin und essen und viel spaß
macht mache das rezept findet ihr auf
facebook funktioniere blog.de und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß dabei und
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
sie wecken wir so nicht aber das macht
es kurz
[Musik]